you know for you you've you've mentioned
in other interviews that an early TV
influence for you was of course Star
Trek and in that time Gene Roddenberry's
universe was more diverse than some of
the universes we see on contemporary
television and I know you're also
producing an adaptation of Nattie okura
force who fears death which is exciting
for many many reasons but one of them I
think is that people seem to have an
increasing hunger for sci-fi and fantasy
and speculative fiction that reflects
the diversity of our worlds is that
something that's important to you or
something you're thinking about yeah I
think I think we have to move in that
direction but I also think science
fiction has always done better than the
society in general neither it's perfect
by any means but the science fiction I
like best it's a lot of kinds of science
that you notice and fantasy I mean
besides that it's fantasy there's urban
fantasy there's dark fantasy
there's fairy tales there's cyberpunk
and science fiction there's there's
space software there are many many kinds
of things the the sort of science
fiction I grew up on that I loved most
of all was the stuff that was set out
among the stars and where we would go to
alien planets a hundred years in the
future five hundred years in the future
and meat meat alien strange life-forms
distant Suns it just appealed to me
because that travel thing I liked the
exotic flavors and and the see sights
never seen before
go places no one had ever gone before
what I didn't realize though when I was
reading that and I realized that as an
adult many many decades later it's that
the we who was going out in those
starships and the science-fiction that I
read in the 50s and 60s they weren't
Americans they weren't Chinese or
Brazilians or French they were earth men
or Earthlings or Terrans those were two
terms that were made
and so if we were gonna meet the octopus
people of the third planet of Vega it
would be Terrans meeting them and we
would be part of the solar alliance or
the United planets or something like
that and some of the authors at the time
made a deliberate effort at diversity
maybe they didn't entirely succeed but
you know you look at someone like Paul
Anderson and he would have you would
have Scotsman an Irishman but also
Polynesians and and Brazilians L Sprague
de Kamp wrote a whole series in which
Brazil was the dominant power of 23rd
century earth so that message was always
there it was there in the Pope magazines
and in early science fiction and Gene
Roddenberry brought it to to television
Roddenberry the original Star Trek had
some good episodes and it had some
really bad episodes but it was very
exciting to to see it at the time and
Roddenberry was immensely courageous if
nothing else and maybe he wasn't the
greatest writer to come down the pike or
the greatest showrunner but you look
back at the show that came out in 1967
he put a black woman on the bridge as
communications engineer he put an Asian
as helmsman he put a Russian at the
height of the Cold War a Russian on the
bridge he was selling the idea that his
Federation Earth had put together all of
its differences and we'd all come
together as a single people and maybe
most shocking of all although was Spock
because Spock was you think of spark as
a Vulcan he wasn't a Vulcan he was a
half-breed he was half Vulcan
and he was half human he had green blood
and two hearts and a Vulcan father and a
human mother
if you're a hard science fiction
it makes no [ __ ] sense we're nothing
we're not actually gonna be able to
interbreed with the octopus people in
Vega it doesn't work that way any any
more than we can you know impregnate
wombats here on earth but nonetheless
what's striking about Spock when this
when this came out in 1967 is the fact
that at the time he was doing this
miscegenation was still against the law
in in half the states in the United
States this was before loving versus
Virginia which was that the the famous
case recently dramatized in a movie that
established that a white man could
actually marry a black woman that was
against the law and interracial marriage
having children with people of another
race and he's he's having half-breed
Vulcans I mean it was enormous ly
progressive at the time and I didn't
really notice it because I've been
reading about that stuff for a long time
but looking back on it now and realizing
that you know books that sell 3,000
copies are one thing but a television
show that reaches twenty thirty million
people is another and these things
influence us they they really reflect us
and now in science fiction fantasy we
are seeing a great up swell of diverse
voices by many many different sorts of
people different skin colors different
religions different sexual orientations
and they're producing your own takes on
this and as with any other groups some
are good some of them are not so good
but I think it's a healthy a healthy
sign for the genre I do hope that
there's still room for some old white
guys like me because I'm I don't know
there's only two seats here
[Laughter]
I'm gonna ask you I think one or two
more questions and then I'm gonna go to
these fan questions right I think my
final question will be this you are a
very frequently and many times
interviewed person you've been
interviewed a lot
what is the interview question that you
wish people would ask and what is the
one that you do not like or that you
load the most with apologies to anyone
who has previously asked you this
question including me if I'm one of the
people it's not personal it's just that
I'm asking so question you wish people
would ask in question you hate the most
well obviously these days the question I
hate the most is when when will win some
winter but yeah because I have no good
answer for that I mean when the day
comes that wins the winter is done and I
can say when I asked that question
October that will be a happier time for
me but it's it's no fun to be asked
repeatedly the same question over and
over again and you don't have a good
answer for it there are a lot of
questions I won't say I hate them but
you know I've been asked them so often
that it gets a little tiresome you know
and and it also shows that however much
the person may be a huge fan of mine
they've never actually gone online and
looked at any of the hundred and
thirty-seven other interviews of me that
you can find on youtube I mean which is
your favorite character which character
you like to write the most which
character you like right the least you
know I've been answering that question
since 1996 so and there are a number of
questions that fall in that category as
to a question that I've want to be asked
that's harder I don't think I have one
question I do like the fact that in your
questions you've discussed some things
other than Game of Thrones I mean I love
Game of Thrones I love Game of Thrones I
love strong of Ice and Fire
but I do have a long
history of writing other things and I'm
very happy and proud of some of those
things too and it's fun to discuss
things you know that I haven't been
asked about before and you know to talk
about fever dream or Armageddon rag or
the wild card series or you know we're
dying a light or any of my myriad short
stories that I've that I've written over
the years so well good I'm glad if you
hated one of my questions that you're
keeping that to yourself for the time
very polite of you